i love
public displays of romance i don't know
that i would love a proposal i do think
that a proposal is a kind of a a sacred
intimate thing that should just be
between two people um when you're about
to pledge your lives to each other ben
affleck we hope you're taking notes
because jennifer lopez knows what she
wants when it comes to a proposal it's
really about
recognizing your own value during a
recent appearance on the heart fm radio
show the actress who is currently dating
the live by night star reveals why she's
against public proposals despite being
all for pda i think that that's a more
intimate thing between two people but i
have no problem with you know like pda
like people say i actually i'm all about
it if you really feel it but i um i do
think that a proposal is a kind of a a
sacred intimate thing that should just
be between two people um when you're
about to pledge your lives to each other
that's a big deal and j.lo practices
what she preaches last week at the
premiere for her latest project marry me
she and ben did not shy away from
showing off how much they adore each
other
this is just a good date night it's a
great date night we're super happy
um what can i tell you we're just having
a good time i would be remiss if i
didn't say you were standing taking
photos in front of a sign that says
marry me
it's very big i didn't really realize
how big
[Laughter]
now jen and ben may not be that far away
from taking that next step because a
source tells et the couple is open to
the possibility of getting engaged and
married i've heard you say so many times
that you are a hopeless romantic and you
still believe in love you believe in
marriage so like cat you still believe
in all of those absolutely why wouldn't
i
the source goes on to say that jen feels
like their love story is like a fairy
tale between them and like they're meant
to be quote she is so incredibly in love
with him ben is so funny and confident
he is always telling jen she can do
anything he is not scared or intimidated
by her money or success it just turned
out to be something really magical and
don't worry if a proposal happens the
two have their family stamp of approval
our source reveals that ben's kids
really like jen and her kids love ben
gushing that he is incredible around
them and makes them all laugh thesaurus
says their loved ones would not be
surprised if ben pops the question
you